[Música]
revista al prensa en directo américa de
france 24 rosa pérez masdéu conmigo ya
en el estudio de rosa ya estamos a mitad
de semana muy buena mañana de miércoles
vamos a abrir esta revista de prensa con
las portadas británicas que señalan la
crisis en el gobierno de boris johnson
tras la cascada de renuncias de los
ministros no es exactamente por un lado
es destacable que en muchísimos medios
británicos y de los más importantes como
the gardian the times como vamos a ver
ahora piden abiertamente y directamente
la renuncia del primer ministro sin
embargo no es la primera vez en las
últimas semanas ni en los últimos meses
en los últimos meses que vemos a boris
johnson un poco dilapidado en las
portadas británicas justo ahora antes de
entrar estaba repasando las portadas del
día siguiente de esa moción de confianza
ese voto de confianza que también
comentamos aquí y que johnson ganó por
una estrecha mayoría de hecho obtuvo el
41 por ciento de oposición es decir el
41 por ciento de los conservadores que
votan no creían ya que boris johnson
pudiera continuar al frente líder el
partido conservador ni por supuesto pues
el gobierno británico y en ese momento
ya titulaban vencedor debe herido el
líder debilitado en fin no vamos a ver
por eso como aumenta digamos esta
presión mediática para que boris johnson
dimita hay tres puntos claves rosa
va a mencionar antes de que comience a
realizar las portadas el primero por
supuesto el más fuerte el pari gate
luego también los señalamientos además
hasta de la realeza británica que están
en contra de estas deportaciones de los
migrantes puede que entran por el canal
de la mancha que los envían a ruanda
pues están en ese proceso legal
recordemos que ese avión el primero no
salió pero pues el gobierno está
intentando que realmente si se de esta
deportación en ruanda y el último que
fue el que desencadenó todas estas
renuncias masivas fue el diputado del
partido conservador que está ya 16
denuncias de acoso sexual parece que
cuando él se emborracha pues empieza a
tocar indebidamente a las personas
efectivamente es el caso de crispín ser
que en un primer momento
boris johnson aseguró que no tenía
constancia de que tenía sobre él pesaban
a denuncias como bien dices de acoso
sexual pero recordemos ayer un alto
funcionario de downing street señaló
públicamente que sí que johnson había
sido advertido de las denuncias que
pesan sobre este diputado conservador
por lo que se señaló de nuevo las
mentiras de boris johnson o como bien
decías algo que recuerda mucho a su
posicionamiento público de cara al
escándalo del parque gate bien así te
parece empecemos como vemos aquí con the
times que como vemos aquí johnson on the
brink al borde del abismo y precisamente
hemos señalado cuatro portadas
británicas que todas utilizan esta misma
formulación on the brink al borde del
abismo y bien señalan y destacar también
que cuando seguramente estos medios
mandaron las rotativas e imprimir ayer
por la noche hora británica de momento
sólo habían ha dimitido rich y sunat el
que era hasta ayer de hecho el
secretario de finanzas y 6 y davis el
secretario de salud pero como bien decía
si nos contaba luisa desde a estas
renuncias que son las de cargos más
destacables ya se han sumado más de una
decena de renuncias a nuevas por eso
digamos se habla tanto de crisis
gubernamental y precisamente the times
opina cada día que permanece en el cargo
boris johnson profundiza la sensación de
caos por el bien del país debería irse
lo que ha llevado a johnson a esta
posición son los mismos defectos de
carácter que han perseguido toda su
carrera su persistente mentira y
flagrante desprecio por los códigos y
convenciones que necesariamente
sustentan la vida pública por otro lado
the gardian dice la partida de risas
unac y 6 y davis debería anunciar el
final de un primer ministro
desacreditado el primer ministro
necesita ser confrontado con la verdad
su tiempo se acabó y también han
destacar que la situación es tal que the
gardian está haciendo minuto a minuto
con las renuncias que se van dando en el
ejecutivo británico por otro lado the
independant sunat y xavi empujan a
johnson al borde del abismo y también
destaca consum acc un tema que he
mencionado antes pero también es
importante las discrepancias en términos
de política económica de política
impositiva entre es una que johnson no
digamos es una queriendo tener una
posición más tradicionalmente
conservadora de rebajar los impuestos
por otro lado de general vemos una
portada digamos muy
con unas imágenes muy claras por un lado
vemos a zoom acá que a la izquierda que
pone quit ya renunció por otro lado
davis a la derecha renuncio y en medio
la foto de johnson con la pregunta
renunciará bien y finalmente el
financial times cita a los dos
secretarios que han dimitido en su
discurso explicando su renuncia mientras
su nac dijo la gente espera
acertadamente que el gobierno se
comporte adecuadamente competentemente y
seriamente quieren saber la verdad jay
beat dijo el tono que adoptas como líder
se refleja en los valores que representa
es que en tus compañeros en tu partido y
en última instancia en tu país y
terminamos ante todo este panorama
político o abusador en reino unido con
algo de alegría cuando ves tu arrugado
rosa
qué poco voy a arreglar
vamos a ver porque solo pregunto qué
vamos a ver pues precisamente el
frankfurter allgemeine hoy te pone en
portada una imagen muy simpática no que
a las que poco estamos acostumbrados a
ver en las portadas internacionales pone
esta foto este plano de la dama y el
vagabundo esta imagen esta película tan
icónica de disney porque hoy es el
llamado kissing de una tradición que
viene precisamente del reino unido y que
se traduce a la mundo hispanohablante
como día del beso robado y pide el
'frankfurter allgemeine' que
aprovechemos que parece que la pandemia
ya no es tan grave no como ha sido en
los últimos años para darnos un poco
pues de amor y de amistad entre todos
alrededor besos rosa muchísimas gracias
entonces portual información nos vemos
mañana cómo hacer revista de prensa
saludamos a nuestro primer invitado